this scene originally was the beginning  of Toy Story 4 as a cold open which  means that there was no setup for it you  just go right into it we were  introducing Bonnie as a creative kid and  then also reintroducing the world to not  just the toys from Andy's house but the  ones that were in Bonnie's room as well  so now seeing all these toys together  for the first time in a play time was  something that was fun to think about  where we were going with the story was  that bonnie was having trouble in school  and she didn't want to read and so  that's why there are books that are kind  of villains in this playtime that  ultimately went nowhere because there  wasn't really no no stakes at all there  this just was an insane play time that  we just went to 11 with it's ridiculous  but it was fun to watch looks like rain  it's worse than grade  [Music]  I'll be safe inside except that guy  [Music]  [Music]  it's playtime  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Music]